good morning John it is Wednesday April
28 2010 welcome to April 28 what is it
what what is April 28th really I just
looked it up its Administrative
Professionals Day Administrative
Professionals out there you guys thank
you so much I don't have any idea what
you do but you administrate you are pros
at it it is also national poetry reading
day and I can definitely get on board
with that
here here's one haikus are easy but
sometimes they don't make sense
refrigerator here's another one of my
favorites I will not play tug of war I'd
rather play hug O'War
where everyone hugs instead of tugs
where everyone giggles and rolls on the
rug where everyone kisses and everyone
grins and everyone cuddles and everyone
wins
I like poetry that doesn't confuse me a
lot of poetry I read it I am like I hate
when poets assume that I know what they
mean even when they don't say but shel
silverstein he says what he means he
just says it in a more clever way I'm a
poet so back to hugs and rolling on rugs
a little while ago there was a
nerdfighter in the comments who said
something in the comments I don't
remember who it was and I'm sorry to
that person but they left a comment
saying something about a bucket list of
hugs a bucket list for those of you who
don't know is a list of things you would
like to do before you kick the bucket
and for those of you who don't know what
kicking the bucket is it is a bizarre
American euphemism for dying so of
course I immediately shortened this
sentiment to the hug bucket so your hug
bucket is the bucket that all of your
hugs go into and hopefully we have a lot
of them and there are certain people
that you want to get inside of your hug
bucket like for example for me we got
John and John of they might be giants
Wil Wheaton David Tennant Nathan Fillion
say Frank the Mythbusters the founders
of Threadless Felicia Day Jonathan
Coulton uh that guy who holds up the
free hug sign I really want to hug that
guy Helen Hunt of course Kim Stanley
Robinson MC Frontalot Ursula league win
these people these people that I love
that I love and I've never met them but
I just want to hug them because I'm so
impressed with the stuff that they do
and youtubers so many youtubers that I
want a hug that I haven't hugged yet
which is not to say that my hug bucket
is not in a good position like I think
my
huh bucket is is sturdy well-formed and
quite full hug bucket everyday I get to
add more hugs from the Catherine and
there's no hugs that I would rather have
in my hug bucket there are plenty of
hugs from John Green there's hugs from
Alex Day and Charlie McDonnell there's
hugs from shaycarl
oh my awesome friends and family all
those people in my hug bucket and let's
not kid ourselves VidCon is going to be
very good for my hug bucket it's gonna
get bigger but additionally I'm going to
add two and a half names from the list
that I just mentioned in a couple of
weeks not very long from now because I'm
going to be playing whoot stock in
Portland and Seattle on the 7th and 8th
of May I'm gonna get to meet and hang
out with Adam Savage MC Frontalot will
freakin Wheaton and a bunch of other
like epically awesome nerds and I am
going to without a doubt be playing what
would Captain Picard do in front of Wil
Wheaton who in my head is still Wesley
Crusher now this geek and song fest is
definitely pg-13 it might even be PG 15
or 16 but tickets are available now and
you can go to the links in the
doobly-doo if you live in Portland OR
Seattle and you can see me play a
10-minute set among three hours of
festival of Awesome but what I want to
know now is who is in your hug bucket
and don't just say me because you know I
know you want to hug this tell me who is
in your hug bucket John I will see you
on Friday
you wanna on this your
then I'll get me some more Robin you
want all this you're not this guy no you
want a hug